good morning my name is Ben Busby I'm
the genomics outreach coordinator for
NCBI and I'd like to introduce you to
the NCBI Assembly database we'll have a
closed caption recording of this video
on our YouTube channel you can see the
URL below and please subscribe to our
YouTube channel tell your friends if
your question does not get answered
please either email webinars at NCBI NLM
NIH gov and if there are common
questions we can't get to for whatever
reason we'll post the answers those
questions in their answers on our FTP
site great alright so today I'm going to
talk about obtaining genome sequences
and annotations with NCBI assembly and
my personal view right now assembly is
the fastest easiest way to get genome
sequences and annotations from NCBI and
I'll talk about why that is over the
next few slides first I want to talk
about the new human genome assembly
grch38 grch38 fixes almost a thousand
low side from grch37 and there are about
a hundred and seventy-eight alternate
Llosa these are particularly important
for immunological irrelevant regions of
the human genome for example if you're
talking about some sort of
immunoglobulin locus it does not make
sense to have a human reference
immunoglobulin locus and that's why we
have alternate low-side so please
consider using grch38 for your analyses
in this room more details on the
differences between 37 and 38 as well as
mouse 37 verses 38 can be found at the
genome reference consortium website
shown here just google genome reference
consortium if I go to assembly and I
google Homo sapiens what I will see is
the latest patch for grch38 is obviously
P 3 I can click on that and
then go into the FTP site I'll show you
how to bridge those two things in just a
couple of minutes what I see here is I
can grab the nucleotide fast a the GF f3
annotations by the way we're going to be
releasing GTF annotations probably in
the next six to nine months I could also
see protein sequences as well as RNA
sequences and their annotations many
people also want to get sequences from
other organisms particularly bacteria so
we have about 20,000 bacterial genomes
that are available for download in
refseq and about 30,000 available for
download in GenBank real quick for those
of you who are somewhat new to this the
big difference between genbank and
refseq here GenBank are sequences and
annotations that have been submitted by
the user community we do not adulterate
them in any way refseq we typically
don't change the sequences much for
genomes except maybe to put in
mitochondrial sequences that's for the
pure genomes for proteins things can
change a little bit but sometimes we do
put in new annotations based on our
annotation pipelines which I will show
you in a little bit so what might think
you would want to go to genomes at NCBI
to download genome sequences but what
the genome database does right now is it
shows genomes in their general context
with respect to each other
so what I have here is and actually more
likely species context with respect to
each other
here I have the several thousand
Mycobacterium tuberculosis species for
which we have sequences and you can see
a tree here with obviously quite a few
of the nodes collapsed substantially our
intention over the next nine months to a
year is to make this tree totally
interactive going down to the individual
strain level from which you will be able
to link to assembly but we have not
enabled that functionality yet please be
on the lookout for a
where we will actually solicit user
input on how that resource should be
laid out right now like I said I think
the best place to get sequences for
individual strains is from the assembly
database so if I search assembly for
Mycobacterium tuberculosis I get the
very well studied for example age 37 RV
straight up at the top if I want to look
at all of the age 37 RV strains we
possess I can certainly do that in the
assembly database and we can see where
they are submitted from and when they
were submitted if I go to an individual
age 37 RV record the really nice thing
is these two links on the right to the
genbank and refseq FTP sites apologize
that this slide got a bit distorted and
then I can go and I can if I click on
that link particularly for refseq I can
get the fast day I can get the
annotations protein fasting and
annotations now the thing we've done
with the fast day and I'm very proud to
say we've done this is we have changed
our genomic fast eight files such that
they will work with popular RNA seek
analysis software such as bowtie hiset
and star so if you index these genomes
for both set bowtie high set or star and
then you use cufflinks cuffdiff or de
seek you will get actual expression
transcript expression values or gene
expression values depending on what
you're trying to do so that's a fairly
useful thing to know I think right now
well one thing to remind you guys who
are doing that kind of work is that
remember the accession in the fast day
has to match exactly with the accession
in the GFF 3 or GTFO so right now I
would suggest not mixing annotations
from UCSC or ensemble with genomes from
NCBI
although we do intend to make a
converter in the near future
also if things have not been submitted
as full genomes if they've been
submitted justice context you can get
those out of the nucleotide database the
easiest way to dump those sequences is
to go to the send to button this is an
often underestimated button in the NCBI
Pantheon if you go to the send to button
you can send them to a fast a file as
shown here I wanted to talk a little bit
about our genome annotation pipelines
these are user questions that get quite
a bit and if you have other questions
about our annotation pipelines please
email us and webinars at NCBI MLM this
is our prokaryotic annotation pipeline
if you submit us bacterial genomes as
Pontic scaffolds or preferably as whole
chromosomes we will annotate your
bacteria for you also we have a
eukaryotic annotation pipeline that's
something that's obviously quite a bit
more complex and you can read very
extensive documentation about that at
this URL shown here also this is a basic
diagram showing that we essentially
throw the kitchen sink at these
annotations these are annotations based
on perceived need from the community the
ranking of these annotations is based on
perceived need for the community so if
you believe that there is a genome that
really needs to be annotated by NCBI
please email genomes at NCBI NLM NIH gov
and we will consider your request if you
have any other questions about
eukaryotic genome annotation please
e-mail genomes at ncbi NLM NIH dr.
wanted to talk just a little bit about
de novo RNA seek assembly we do house
quite a bit of data in that realm
although not typically in mouse or human
but in non-model organisms we house we
have millions of Records for de novo or
an AC cassette
and those can be found in the
transcription shotgun archive which is
part of the nucleotide database I can
talk about that more extensively if
anybody has questions finally I would
like to thank a large amount of people
for their contributions to these
databases as well as their help with
putting together these this presentation
and for the next five to ten minutes or
so I'll be available to take any
questions thank you very much I hope all
of you have a fantastic day
and for those of you on the East Coast
welcome to spring thank you alright so
there's a pretty good question as a rank
beginner to assembly where would you
suggest I begin what I would do is go to
the assembly database and I would dive
in headfirst I would go to the assembly
database and I would look for your
genome of interest and I would try to
download the fast a file and do whatever
it is you want to do one thing so I
teach you a lot of bioinformatics
courses and one thing I often tell my
students is it is best to start with a
biological question when you're doing
computational things because you are
most likely a biologist so do we have
any assemblers on NCBI we do not have
assemblers on NCBI it's a good question
there are a couple of websites that
outline assemblers I cannot endorse
anybody's product so I can't speak to
pros and cons of different assemblers
but what I can say is omics tools.com is
a pretty good place to look for a sort
of just a listing fools for this type of
thing including assemblers some popular
ones are velvet soap denovo abyss
there's a bunch of them also
Brewed has a an assembler comparer
called met Bemis so you might want to
check that out can one download plasmid
genomes yes you can we don't have a ton
of them
and often they will come with whatever
bacterial species that they were
discovered with so they will be listed
separately in the FTP site and some of
my colleagues may wish to weigh in on
that that's something we've been talking
about a lot so if they have more we'll
put them in the FTP site linked from the
video that's a great question if there
are no other questions oh by the way the
NCBI please subscribe to our YouTube
channels and by the way are the NCBI
minute is going to change from 9:45
we're gonna move until noon to make
things a bit easier for our friends on
the west coast
so the next NCBI minute will be May 6th
I will actually talk about PubMed
Commons and will be fantastic and it
will be at noon Eastern Time all right
well thank you very much everybody and
have a great day